marketing fails i love marketing fails
there's always so many people and so
much money involved into a decision
that ends in disaster i love it check
out number one
dobbs body positive packaging god was
trying to sell what do they sell it's
soap isn't it yeah body wash and they
thought
not just body wash also
body positive body wash so they changed
the
size of all the the shape of all the
cans
basically i don't think this is a big
deal at all i don't actually understand
why people were mad
it's time now to bring out the pretty
people and i
d double
[Music]
[Applause]
who looked like this though huh
imagine imagine having this shape and be
like oh that's me
thank you i understand that's probably
not what they meant
my god oh oh look it's
that's me if everyone beautiful then
no one beautiful we need ugly people
though you don't understand your own
definitions pro tip don't buy a bottle
for your girlfriend's
wife and tell her it matches her shape
i mean this one dude look kind of funky
though all right
number two that's right i'm a tough
tearless channel now
uh this one is my favorite it's my
favorite probably
i don't know we'll see it's susan boyle
remember susan boyle
says susan boy she's huge
you britain singer so good but so ugly
well with all her success they decided
hey let's release an album
makes sense right we should create some
sort of hashtag to create hype for this
album
okay sure what hashtag should we use
hashtag
susan album party to get people excited
about the album coming out oh no
it reads seuss sues anal
bum party a sus anal bomb party
hey anyone checking out the susanna sus
album
anyone going to the sush ain't no party
later
catch you guys there the thing is i mean
the point of marketing is to
create attention to something and surely
this did the trick right
so in a way it's genius but also i have
never heard of susan boyle after this
event and i remember this happening
so maybe not all publicity
number three mac africa sounds bad just
saying it like that
okay so norway decided to release a new
burger with authentic recipe from africa
calling it mac africa delicious
now you may think there's no problem
with this and you are right
until you realize that they released
this during the famine
in africa
there was a famine in zimbabwe malawi
swaziland
zambia in norway being one of the
richest nations in the world
you lucky son of a [ __ ] you find oil
you're lucky all right you're lucky we
let you go from sweden
god damn you norway just rubbing it in
everyone's faces
chewing on your mac africa everyone's so
poor
everyone's starving we have so much oil
this one makes me actually angry i also
like that uh you know
mcdonald's isn't one of those spineless
corporations they get called for
backlash they say no
they didn't actually remove the burger
they went forward with it
they stood the ground and said pc
culture too far all right
the norwegians want their mac africa
they get their mac africa
[ __ ] you it tastes better knowing people
starving
which number am i on number four yeah
number four
okay this is uh back from the glory days
when mark zuckerberg was uh
prominent online and this one kind of i
don't know if i reacted to this because
it's a beautiful clip
so mark wants to market his new vr
technology
he brought up rachel next to him i think
they're in different rooms
and uh to display just how you can go
anywhere with vr they thought they'd go
to puerto rico
where there's just been a disaster a
hurricane
and you can kind of get a
sense of what is we're on a bridge here
um it's it's flooded uh
okay all right fine i guess they're
working with
the red cross to help somehow i don't
know how
but the thing is
mark is so disassociated with what is
going on
they just don't care
yeah high five people lost their home
sci-fi
mark zuckerberg richest man on the
planet let's go
this is so cool we're high-fiving can
you imagine being in puerto rico
you lost your home knowing that
billionaires are high-fiving over your
property
being completely flooded yeah can you
can you guys see this behind me i mean
this is completely flooded high five
crazy to feel like you're in the middle
of it yeah except you're not
you're not dealing with it at all you're
in l.a all right silicon valley i don't
[ __ ] with that
it's funny because they're dumb okay
i've never made any mistake okay number
five
i just thought this was a funny story i
feel like i heard about it before maybe
you have as well
so a and v i didn't know they even made
food i thought they made
the uh root beer anyway sorry america i
don't know
mcdonald's has the quarter pounder
cheeseburger whatever
who cares famous burger delicious looks
so yummy so amv thought they'd
they compete with mcdonald's but they
thought hey let's do it better
what's more than a quarter pounder a
third pounder
a third is more than a quarter everyone
knows this you get more meat
it's the best burger who can contest
this well
americans americans very dumb i don't
know if this is true or not but they
they say that the reason it failed
was because people couldn't identify
that a
quarter pounder is actually less than a
third pounder or three pounder
people didn't understand how fractions
work but three
smaller than four i'm not gonna pay off
what hey the average person did not
understand fractions
is this true i don't know if this is
true maybe they just failed and they're
like ah people dumb
huh they're too dumb to buy a burger
stupid people
stupid idiots i had a faint memory of
this
this is from 2012. yeah yeah i remember
do you guys remember this hitman you
know the game where you assassinate
people i
surprised launched a marketing campaign
where you can connect
the game as far as i understand it you
can connect the game with your
facebook account so you can assassinate
your friends
epic right okay questionable sure
but the thing is you could add they they
prompted these decisions of okay so you
can identify him
by his tiny penis
reason for target elimination has a
really bad taste in music
it's kind of funny actually i don't know
if i have any problems with this
until i mean it gets weirder right they
have one that said
assassinate her for her small tastes
her muffin top her hair it's ginger hair
i mean that's
almost called for your friend then
received a personal video on their
facebook wall identified
them as a target
i want to see it is there any footage
please target identified
by her small tits please please show
video
i hope you get killed by a hitman oh
that's up
okay i'm starting to see i'm starting to
understand oh they took down the website
so it would show up a photo of you oh so
it sounded like a video we can't see the
video oh i'm so sad
oh that's brilliant i love it i'm
actually not mad number six
this one i actually remember it was uh a
competition for
walmart where you can vote to
have pitbull the great singer and artist
mr worldwide himself will go anywhere
he will go to any walmart store that
people on facebook vote for
you can win a visit from pitbull the
dream
the dream i whine now it looks like
people were actually excited about this
hot pitbull when is the deadline i just
found out this
i am a fan i need to meet him now
now the internet took this in their own
hands and all voted to send him to the
most
furthest remote walmart there is in
alaska
also fitting kodiak alaska which is from
his famous line
picture that with a kodiak i feel like
this is the campaign where marketing
people just realize okay we can never
give the internet any power
whatsoever but yeah people uh
people actually went to [ __ ] kodiak
alaska
which big props to him it looked like a
great time but
i don't know maybe i would go to alaska
i would love to go
at least he honored the deal right
[Music]
i respect that in a way he played for an
audience that looks about like
300 people pretty cool people sprayed
him with bear spray
during the mist
number 10 last but not least the pepsi
commercial that changed everyone's life
the commercial that had such an impact
that
people still reference it kendall jenner
saving the world with pepsi
i love this one because millions and
millions and millions and millions of
dollars went into this commercial right
can you imagine how much they paid her
like come here
take the pepsi give the pepsi to the
guard it will be [ __ ] awesome
people will love it pieces made with
pepsi
capture that with a kodiak yeah
where was kendall jenner in 2020 huh
when we really needed her
perhaps this pandemic would never ever
happen number nine
that's right you thought it was over it
keeps going the journal pizza
hell yeah pizza everyone love pizza so
on twitter sometimes there's uh hashtags
that gets trending
and the journal saw that why i stayed
was trending
and posted why i stayed you had pizza
what did giorno
clearly didn't know was that why i
stayed was a hashtag related to domestic
abuse
respected funny
oh it went from a [ __ ] joke
domestic view is not funny but
it is kind of funny they apologized and
went on with their life
and on that note i also apologize
nothing is funny
people make mistakes okay sometimes you
gotta push
boundaries a little bit to know where
they are no harm no foul
if you enjoyed this video smash like
subscribe more videos every single day
baby i'll see you tomorrow brofist
ah caught you you're using internet
without a vpn
cringe look at this dude sign up with
nordvpn today
and stop being crazy for those who don't
know a vpn it helps you browse the
internet safely
but most importantly freely get past
annoying country restrictions
i can definitely say that so many times
you try and watch a show and it's like
ah
can't watch it there i got you every
time it's like yeah no problem there's
no vpn i already have the subscription
it's all done i don't have to think
about it it's one of those things that's
really just
it's just good to have i recommend it if
you sign up for a two-year plan with
nordvpn
you get a huge discount plus a one month
additional for free
so if you take that offer it's really
good you sign up using the code
pewdiepie
that's how you get epic access to it
you're welcome
if that wasn't good enough for you and
you're not sure if a vpn is really worth
it or not for you
you can try it risk free for 30 days
with a money back guarantee nordvpn
doesn't compromise on speed it's super
fast i use it all the time i can't tell
a difference if i'm using it or not
there's absolutely no data logging
whatsoever
so be safe out there gamers use nordvpn
i recommend it that's nordvpn.com
pewdiepie link in description thank you
for sponsoring
this video